c'est l'une des plus importantes
collections napoléonienne le château de
versailles expose peintures et
sculptures des avoirs représentant
l'empereur les événements de son époque
ses grandes victoires comme celle du
pont d'arcole de marengo ou encore
d'austerlitz mais aussi des
personnalités de son entourage des
offres qui ont toutes été pratiquement
pour l'essentiel commandé par napoléon
pour ces pour sa propre communication et
qui ont été rassemblés ici à versailles
par louis-philippe quand il a créé ces
galeries historique de versailles dans
les années 1830
parmi les oeuvres exposées bonaparte au
pont d'arcole napoléon passant le grand
st bernard ou encore le tableau du sacre
une oeuvre emblématique du premier
empire
réalisé par david c'est un tableau
évidemment qui est une recomposition
d'une scène historique puisque l'artiste
a ouvert la scène est finalement sur le
devant pour que le spectateur participe
de l'action du tableau vraiment on a
l'impression d'être vraiment dans le
public de participer en fait à cet
événement du sacre certains artistes de
l'entourage de david lui ont suggéré de
représenter l'empereur couronnant
l'impératrice qui était une eu un geste
plus auguste et qui avait plus de plus
d'alluré pour le tableau
[Musique]
premier consul stratège général dans les
armées de la république
l'empereur controversé a marqué
l'histoire de france il laisse en
héritage plusieurs institutions un
système administratif en particulier sur
lequel nous vivons encore beaucoup
aujourd'hui c'est aujourd'hui la
structure de l'état français est
complètement un héritage de l'époque de
napoléon avec la création de certaines
institutions comme le conseil d'état la
banque de france la préfecture les
lycées la collection napoléonienne
château de versailles recense 400
tableaux et 200 sculptures
[Musique]